the struggle to save the already
endangered green sea turtle faces a
major new challenge they nearly vanished
40 years ago in Florida but a
coordinated effort by conservatives at
conservationists government agencies and
volunteers brought the animals back from
the brink
now the males of the species appear to
be fewer in number mark Strassmann is on
the beach in Boca Raton Florida with the
newest threat to sea life mark good
morning
good morning
both of these are sea turtle nests at
the height of hatching season under the
sand of each nest like this you might
find a hundred eggs or more and from
five miles up and down this Beach there
are more than 650 sea turtle nests
greens leatherbacks
and loggerheads sea turtles are an
endangered species and the males in
particular seem to be disappearing in a
beachfront ritual that dates back more
than 100 million years we came upon this
300 pound green sea turtle covering her
beach nest burying maybe one hundred
eggs or more this is what that Turtles
babies will look like biologist jeanette
1ik in directs Florida Atlantic
University's marine lab and a studied
Florida's sea turtle population since
2002 she's alarmed by what she doesn't
see in her tanks of hatchlings we're
safe fewer and fewer and fewer years
where we find males so seven out of the
last ten years we have not found any
males not a single one not a single one
not a single one now get up to 300
pounds releases the species that we're
Taylor Rowe helps collect hatchlings for
one Eakins research on why male sea
turtles seem to be disappearing looks
like we might have close to over a
hundred empty shells which means those
hatchlings made it out and went to the
water it's not genetics that determine a
sea turtle sex
it's the sands temperature the tipping
point is roughly 85 degrees for a
species that is predominantly female if
it's too warm you don't get boys if it's
too cool you don't get girls so it's the
hot chicks and cool dudes what explains
why these nests keep getting warmer
certainly weather and climate change
climate change as Florida's beaches get
hotter species are showing signs of
shutting down sea turtles and possibly
also alligators another reptile whose
eggs skew female and whose sex is
determined by nest temperatures on this
rooftop at the University of North
Florida biologist Adam Rosenblatt's
built twenty nests of twenty alligator
eggs apiece this plastic will
artificially warm the nests by five
point five degrees that's how much
hotter North Florida is expected to be
by the end of this century if it's
happening in sea turtles my thought was
it could be happening in alligators as
well and it could throw off that balance
between males and females back in why
nickens lab she uses a mini camera to
determine their sex after they reach six
weeks old so I have to wait till they're
big enough for me to sort of look under
their skirts last night wine again steam
released hundreds of hatchlings into the
sea to the admiration of dozens of
turtle fans
she knows the odds are already long for
this prehistoric species more so now
that climate change is in play there's
some resilience in there that we as
scientists may not have discovered and
then there's part of us that says things
are changing so fast compared to what's
happened in the past that resilience may
not be enough
there's something to see see turtles
don't reach sexual maturity until
they're at least 25 years old so the
impact of these disappearing male
hatchlings may not be known for another
generation Vlad mark Strassmann really
fascinating thank you very much